il s'agit d'un endroit qui pourrait éventuellement
exister et il pourrait exister tout autour de nous,
nous ne le savons tout simplement pas, c'est une
lutte pour la survie de la forêt au
fond de chaque forêt cachée à l'
œil humain où nous voyons les saisons
changer il y a en fait un  une grande guerre
se déroule entre le bien et le mal ouais
tu es avec nous maintenant
Leafman sont ces guerriers qui
protègent fondamentalement Mère Nature si notre
monde meurt, votre monde mourra bientôt la
force du mal que j'ai appelée l'abondance et les
bobines infectent les arbres et affectent le
le sol affecte les racines et provoque la
mort Je vais détruire la forêt
ne vous flattez pas c'est vraiment à
propos de la façon dont tout dans notre vie se
connecte Mary Catherine est
une jeune femme très volontaire donc c'est
ironique qu'elle soit la personne qui se
rétrécit  ce monde magique que son père a
découvert et elle sait qu'elle
doit être impliquée dans cette bataille de miss d'
ici êtes-vous
vous